les épis de blé tendre ont déjà presque
disparu dans cette plaine de la petite
bosse du loiret la moissonneuse batteuse
va même bientôt rejoindre sans regard et
les agriculteurs tirent un premier bilan
plutôt satisfaisant de la récolte 2018
les rendements sont bons la qualité
correcte aussi récolte satisfaisante en
ce qui concerne les blés tendres
les colzas sont plutôt bons rendements
aussi les georges à un peu décevante en
terme de quantitatif et qualitatif mais
on va sur une année on va dire correct
une bonne nouvelle après les inondations
de 2016 et les aléas de 2017
mais la récurrence des phénomènes
interpelle les céréaliers et le
réchauffement climatique bouleverse le
calendrier on avait l'habitude ya vingt
ans de les finir
20 25 juillet au sommet au dos et fil du
temps s'aperçoit que les années où on
finit au 14 juillet sont de plus en plus
nombreuses voilà et ça va être le cas
cette année en principe au 14 juillet on
aura fini la moisson depuis le début de
l'année un nouvel outil de surveillance
des effets du climat est en action en
centre val de loire
le programme oracle et mis en oeuvre par
la chambre régionale d'agriculture et va
collecter des centaines de milliers
d'informations pour déterminer l'avenir
du secteur céréales et régionaux
l'impact n'est plus flagrant cette
fameuse évolution des rendements des
grandes cultures
on avait historiquement depuis 50 ans
une augmentation de rendement d'un
quintal par hectare et par an qui depuis
les années 2000 stagne et les
climatologues nous annonce des choses
avec l'augmentation du nombre de jours
très chaud
par exemple alors que ce que j'appelle
nos jours très chaud c'est plus de 25
degrés qui va avoir lieu au mois de mai
juin pendant la phase de remplissage du
grain des céréales qu'on appelle et qui
va forcément pénalisé très lourdement le
rendement si les scénarios des
climatologues se confirme nos plaines
céréalières pourraient être différentes
dans quelques décennies plus de cultures
d'hiver est sans doute un nouveau
calendrier de récoltes pour échapper aux
probables allongement des périodes de
sécheresse